does being an artist mean being better
than everyone else at your craft no no
no no no
um
it's so funny to me that competitiveness
is taught in a subjective field like I
went to Conservatory for music and it
was a violent Cutthroat deeply
pessimistic Society like Society school
not a society felt like a society
um so many of my cohort had depression
and were like struggling with mental
illness and definitely my own mental
illness like took a bad nosedive while I
was in conservatory and looking back on
it I'm just like I can't believe those
professors taught us that you needed to
be competitive and cruel to your fellow
artists to get ahead because art is a
collaborative field especially film like
when I meet people because I still meet
people who are just mean in our industry
and every time I'm like you got a lot of
work I mean it takes hundreds of people
to make a movie and at the end of the
day you want to make it with people who
are like-minded and who are good people
because you're going to be on set for 16
hours and in that 15th hour you want to
not hate everybody around you that's
very important
so
I mean I just don't think that a
Competitive Edge with others is
something productive I'm competitive
with myself like I I track my progress
every quarter every six months every
year and I want to see an upward
trajectory in terms of how I feel about
myself as an artist my craft in terms of
like other skills that I'm working on
and fluency in those skills shall we say
I compete with myself I always want to
keep growing
um I also firmly believe it's my
personal philosophy that we never stop
growing until we choose to and the
second you choose to stop growing is the
second that you start to die so it's um
and I've learned that from other
incredible artists in the music field
actually way back when over when I was
living in Germany for a minute so
yeah I mean I think I think there's a
way to have a healthy competitive spirit
with yourself that isn't going to like
spill over into other people I don't
think that being competitive with others
is productive I really don't
you know I mean it's like we all might
work together someday so like why are we
being toxic it doesn't it's not going to
change my film right to go up to someone
and be like you have a film just like me
it's like that's not gonna make my film
better it's arguably going to make it
worse because now I've left the creative
process for drama
you talked about their two types of
capitalism yeah thinking back to like
Gordon Gekko and Wall Street yeah and
the thought of like the 80s and and it
was all about sort of this Yuppie
lifestyle do you think things are more
competitive now because so many people
have gone through a recession and and uh
a pandemic and the world moves so much
faster with social media cryptocurrency
are we actually more competitive now
I think we're more negative now I I'm in
general for completely valid and
understandable reasons seeing people
lash out quicker be more quick to judge
more quick to get in a fight where it's
like hey whoa I don't know you we're on
the same team like hold on nothing's
burning I feel like I'm having to use
like de-escalation personal skills you
know what I mean to go shopping yeah
we're okay right exactly it's just like
life
um yeah I feel like I'm running into
that more even today like I was on hold
with like customer service for venmo
just like super random thing
um it was just like a really
weirdly hostile call and I'm like wow I
guess I have to stop assuming that
customer service is going to be a thing
anymore because people are so stretched
then you know inflation and recession
simultaneously means people are
starting to go hungry and and we're
starting to see massive turnover and
just like big systemic failure right so
there there are things that are larger
right now than film that are completely
valid in terms of how our like fellow
human is going to behave I think for me
it's just a daily reminder to be like
it's not me and I can also hold space
for that person and be like okay they're
having a hard time how can I be helpful
in this moment how can I like not get in
their Lane in this moment and how can I
also not take it on
I like that that's really good yeah
that's good it's just like that's not
I'm sorry that you're suffering bye
you know is it okay to risk the oh for
lack of a better word the the label of
being too maybe Airy fairy if you're not
and that's a that's a negative term I
know I love it though but but if you're
not really about competition and you're
about like okay I just want to focus on
my lane and what I'm doing then are you
somehow at risk of well then you're too
idealistic and it's like this
Tinkerbell mindset I think if somebody
people project that on me a lot because
I'm a young woman the assumption is that
it's area and not you I I didn't think
you were projecting other random people
have projected that on me in the past
and it's like you know what
we've clearly like you're not seeing me
and you're not hearing me because then
if you did you would be like not every
fairy right with these other individuals
that are coming to mind for me it's like
what would denote someone as Airy fairy
is if they're like stuck in their ideals
and nothing is being made for me it's
like I'm gonna take a project from not
only start to finish but to the highest
possible level that it can go that's
just my work ethic is like if I'm gonna
do a project I am all in I'm gonna eat
sleep and drink that project I'm gonna
put in even unpaid while we're like in
the development let's get fun stage like
minimum of 12 hours a day on a project
Monday through Friday maybe sometimes
weekends as well like I am in it so I
think it's just
for me not being deeply competitive with
others is just a way that I take care of
my mental health so that it's like cool
I don't care what Steve or Jesse or
whoever these people like I don't I
don't care what they're doing I'm
completely focused on this and what I
know needs to happen to make sure that
this film that I'm creating or this
product is going to help the most number
of people because I look at it from that
standpoint right of like what is the
story saying why are we telling the
story now what do I hope the story will
do in terms of impact in the world like
what conversations am I hoping are going
to come up so with that as like the kind
of North Star then it's just about
putting in a lot of work to get there
he said you went to a Music Conservatory
in the Washington state area now in New
York in New York okay yeah yeah and so
what were some of the good things that
they taught aside from the
competitiveness maybe that was infused
or maybe not I'm just projecting my own
my own issues but what were some of the
things that were actually helpful
yeah you know it was really my first
experience in terms of like being
completely immersed in the Arts in a big
city which was I had never had that
before you know it was like growing up
yes I was working professionally in the
Arts but it was still like a side thing
it's you know you're still going to
school and you're being a well-rounded
child and being a child
um so it's the first time that I it was
like nope you're an adult now people are
going to treat you like you're a
professional you're living in the big
city kid you're in New York
um and you're in a place where you get
to again eat drink sleep music all the
time it taught me a lot about balance
and how to have a healthy life doing
that I remember like coming home from a
semester and um
feeling like I couldn't socialize with
people because I was so immersed in what
I was studying that I just wanted to sit
down and like talk about it with people
for hours and everyone was like whoa but
how are you like I'm really not
interested in that because I have a
normal Balanced Life over here in
Washington
um so it was a good lesson too in terms
of how do you switch back and forth
which I know can be a challenge for a
lot of artists right of like um how do
you go from I'm gonna go like
burrow into my script for 10 hours and
then I'm gonna have a normal evening
with my family it taught me how to
balance it taught me how to like
it really taught me how to be an a nerd
about my craft it taught me how to be my
own best teacher where as a teacher and
a mentor that's now a practice that I
use when I'm working with others is just
a like hey like what worked about that
what didn't work let's fine tune the
machine because I think when people have
that level of self-awareness in how they
operate that's when I see like growth
because all of a sudden you're able to
course correct in real time you're not
waiting for somebody else to tell you
what to do you're taking ownership of
yourself as an artist so it fostered all
of those skills and I I really
appreciate you asking me that actually
because I I have never thought about it
in that way before well I would imagine
yeah there was aside from you know
learning how to sort of nose to the
grindstone focus on something that it
there was maybe some things you observed
that yeah helped you so that's
interesting so balanced yeah I guess
that would be difficult if you're so
focused on something and then to go and
hang out with people that have no
association to Industry right yeah
normies yeah Normie is doing Normie
things yeah exactly being like wow what
are you worried about that's so
interesting yeah I mean if
if I'm into any world or subculture
whatever there's going to be different
things that are going to trouble people
but yeah sometimes you
well and also like as artists we're
telling stories that are supposed to
relate to everyone so if we forget how
to relate to people not in our field I
think your your art form is going to
suffer because all of a sudden what
about is it I have a friend who um
writes for Hallmark and they're always
talking about um
the Otto and Myrna like if Otto and
Myrna don't get it then then your script
is too high brow we have to make sure
that Otto and Myrna understand your plot
points which is the most hallmarky thing
that I've heard
um not even sure if I'm supposed to be
saying that but that's fine it's here
now but I like that concept because it's
like a stay relatable you know like go
go down the Art House Rabbit Hole if
that's what you need to do to tell your
story authentically but like make sure
people understand it you don't have to I
just think it's going to be a little bit
more removed you know I mean for me and
and what I want to be doing with my art
I want to make sure that at the very
least the message is understood
um in what I'm saying and and I don't do
a lot of heavy-handed stuff I prefer
like soft touch stories
um that don't go harder than an Erin
Brockovich in terms of like what they
leave people behind with
um yeah this is definitely not I'm not
the producer that's going to be like
this is how you should feel it's like a
here's other perspectives make your own
choice like I can't tell you how to
think right but I want to make sure that
that gets understood and I think if I'm
too distant from people then it won't